this is the money chart to me this is
the most important chart at the moment
we're at 48 000 price point uh there's a
persistent bid in the market and you
tweeted yesterday that the percent of
the supply last active more than one
year ago
is what
second highest highest it's ever been
yep uh so we're about i think in terms
of percentage uh
percentage terms it's about uh 0.3 from
its all-time high of coins that haven't
moved in a year in aggregate terms it's
at an all-time high um back in the
napkin math somewhere around 11 million
or so uh 11 and a half million coins
haven't moved in a year and so
this is what you have this is a reality
and this is why we i pay attention uh to
on chain analytics and this is why
bitcoin uh that number go up technology
is you have a relentless cohort of
stackers and hobblers all over the world
that are buyers of any price and because
of the absolute scarcity because of the
supply and elasticity bitcoin will find
a bid because of these relentless
marginal buyers as marginal sellers get
exhausted that's just the reality of it
and something like this where you see uh
bitcoins never been more kind of scarce
or or more tightly held over a one year
time frame uh just kind of validates
that thesis we can kind of feel it
anecdotally when you're talking to
bitcoin hodlers but this is really just
a way of showing it like the supply
shock the reason bitcoin goes parabolic
is because marginal sellers get
exhausted and new money that comes in
has to bid up the price and so not
saying that we're there yet or we're
going to go parabolic over the next four
months it's no guarantee but what is
showing is that supply health for over
years has never been this tight and i
expect this trend to continue to go up
it's quite exciting i wrote this morning
all about this idea that in september of
2020 as you pointed out we were at uh
all-time high in the supply illiquidity
and we had two persistent buyers we had
microstrategy in the market we had gbt
uh with the arbitrage trade just pouring
billions of dollars in we went from 10
000 to 64 000 between basically uh end
of september 2020 until march of 2021 so
kind of that four to seven month time
period now when we think about that
again the illiquidity matches we see
that for sure in the on-chain metrics
like you're pointing out here we do know
of one persistent buyer buying 125
million dollars or so a day at the
moment that's about 300 percent of the
daily incoming supply will we get other
persistent buyers in what size that's
all up for question but i think what
you're outlining here is when this much
illiquidity is in the market and you
have any amount of persistent buy
pressure it has to move the price in
order to accommodate everyone is that
kind of a fair categorization
yeah 100 and i think you know more so
it's just that the trend is and i see a
lot of you know bitcoin maximalists that
will that love what that what luna is
doing or that hate it uh you know
there's some you know for some reason
there's not really a middle ground but i
think the reality is what dokuan is
doing is completely rational he realized
that and and he just you know if you
listen to his talks it was you know we
basically or do quan rather uh we were
looking for the best sort of collateral
and we wanted something that was neutral
immutable and not not political in any
sort of way and it had a credible
monetary policy and if you're looking
for that the only answer you have in the
world today is bitcoin there's not eth
not solana not any other digital asset
not luna itself it's bitcoin um and so
if we're just thinking about all
protocols or stable algorithmic stable
coins right if you go a level up and i
tweeted this out and you know we were
bantering yesterday about this pump
what is the next logical step if
someone's watching what loon is doing
and what essentially luna is doing is
they're using senior edge from the
appreciation of the token lfg is minting
the luna to ust selling the ust for
tether and buying bitcoin okay long form
they're using luna seniority to purchase
bitcoin what's the rational action for
every single
uh entity that can use seniorish aka
legacy banks nation states
it's to acquire the hardest
money collateral the world's ever seen
to back your currency and i think it's a
no-brainer and something that not a lot
of people have have understood yet
but that's that's what really drives
bitcoin into
outrageous figures that no one can think
possible is
backing your weak unbacked fiat currency
with
absolutely scarce
digital money and i think that's that's
the trend over the long term facts hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time